you can't have a good Pixar movie
without a bunch of Easter eggs right
there are more than a few to spot in
finding dory the long-awaited 2016
sequel to Finding Nemo let's dive in and
find out what you might have missed
during the movie and should go without
saying but there are spoilers ahead
Darla strikes back when Dory gets taken
into the marine life centers quarantine
room she looks over at a bulletin board
with a photo of a very familiar girl
with headgear pinned to it that's right
if you're quick enough you can spot a
picture of Darla the fish tormenting
girl from the original Finding Nemo of
course just why there's a picture of an
Australian girl in a California Marine
Life Center we just can't answer
maybe her reputation for torturing our
Finny friends has spread across the
Pacific Ocean wired the movies to sea
lion characters Luke and rudder are
voiced by Indra Salva and Dominic West
respectively these two actors starred in
the HBO series The Wire with interest
playing russell stringer Bell and West
playing detective Jimmy McNulty as fluke
and rudder they sit on a rock and help
Nemo and Marlin find their way into the
marine Life Center all while keeping
their spots safe from other sea lions
like Gerald my don't you are you maybe
not the same level of drama as the wire
but you take what you can get in a kids
movie a one one three fluke and rudder
also happened to hide another easter egg
as pointed out by the Pixar post blog
merchandise featuring the characters
have tags on their flippers that read a
1 and 13 that's a reference to the
classroom at the California Institute of
the Arts where many of the Pixar and
Disney animators learn their craft and
it's appeared in every Pixar movie ever
released not to mention more than a few
Disney movies - the Pizza Planet truck
rides again you can also spot the famed
Pizza Planet truck from the original Toy
Story when Hank and Dory steal the
transport truck headed for Cleveland
we're not sure how many different Pizza
Planet franchises there are throughout
time and space but this beat-up yellow
truck sure gets around
it's appeared in just about every Pixar
flick wall-e calendar in the scene where
Hank the septa puss hangs from the pipes
above the open ocean tank there's a
small desk in the top right corner of
the screen above that desk is a calendar
that reads
malee it would have also been cool to
see some by and large items littered
around giving some credence to the
theory that these Pixar movies are all
part of the same shared and ultimately
doomed world aperture calendars fine to
Herbie the lovebug
be on the lookout for a familiar face
kind of buried down on the ocean floor
is the world's most famous 1963
Volkswagen Beetle Herbie the lovebug
of course as cues the deep Disney
reference is it's actually pretty creepy
spot for Hermes final resting place who
knows maybe this is one of those Easter
eggs that Pixar sticks into their movies
that hints at a future film maybe
they'll take on a Herbie movie of their
own or better yet maybe he'll make a
comeback in cars three ride reminder
according to ultimate Orlando one of the
pipes in the marine life center reads
sea water supply tl 59 that's a
reference to the Finding Nemo submarine
voyage at Disneyland in Anaheim
California this explanation doesn't stop
there either
the attraction used to be called simply
the submarine voyage but was redeemed
after the success of the film the pipe
was included on the line to the ride as
a tribute to its former non Nemo themed
existence return of the tank gang if you
manage to sit through the credits
enjoying various snippets of hank using
his camouflaging abilities in different
locations then you be treated to a post
credit scene featuring the sea lions
fluke and rudder hanging out on their
rock and who should happen to come
swimming past them the tank gang from
Finding Nemo Brad Garrett Willem Dafoe
and the rest came back to reprise their
roles so we could see where the gang
wound up Hank the greatest Easter egg of
them all did you know that Hank the
septa puss actually appeared in every
one of Pixar's movies without anyone
ever realizing it it's true well at
least according to finding dory director
Andrew Stanton and Hanks voice actor Ed
O'Neill who appeared in a video
explaining that Hank had been
camouflaged into every Pixar movie since
the first Toy Story hit theaters way
back in 1995 wait what oh that video was
published on April 1st 2016 so you never
mind thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Easter eggs
we missed
you